enjoy this life
share life with fiber optic connection all the way home
you can download and upload data at lightning speed
bluray in 33 minutes
DVD in six minutes
300 pictures in 58 seconds
real-time interaction
uninterrupted connection
benefit from this innovation
fiber optic connection to the home
enables many next generation services in and application
remotely  surgery,
remote patient care,
hairy energy distribution network,
smart communication,
high security network systems,
customizable TV
subscribe to the network,
choose when you want, watch it Video
Cloud Computing,
online games, video conference training,
God
improve your business, provide faster, more effective
and better quality communication,
get rid of traffic and work
from home, while you work from home.
reach the world
think about your future fiber
internet to the home brings tomorrow to today
this is a brighter future
subscribe